you can't get anyone to go to the movies
with you why why did why can't why want
anyone to go to the movies I feel like
I'm been in the movies Ben TV stand up
right but I'm the movie cop I love
movies but I'm even a kid I go that
Mustang never had that engine in it I
love cars and it's right Dukes of
Hazzard they peel out and squeal out on
dirt roads yeah he was a kid I went fake
cat happened right so now I'm I'm doing
that with superhero movies because they
Hulk Mark Ruffalo's character plays the
Hulk now but Eric Bana did it for a
while yeah love the superhero movies
grows through two thousand times the
size I'm screaming out in this theater
how come his pants don't fly off guy in
the front cuz I don't want to see a set
of cream balls I was told by your guys
if I said balls I can get it bulls like
Chicago Bulls you can get away with
saying balls yes you can say balls get
HR out here you can't do it we can't
afford HR of course that's great yeah
you get mad at all the superhero movies
well come on Superman isn't anybody at
the Daily Planet it's a newspaper right
doesn't anybody sit there Superman
saving somebody on this team cut Kent
comes around the corner old sweat he
goes hey you know Clark Wow Wow Jesus
Clark take those glasses off and go like
this for me what's with the this cape
yeah remember Edna in the Incredibles
yes yes that's the no capes
we don't do capes right right what's
Superman there's no function for the
cape even Batman it was a wing sort of
thing but yeah yeah yeah
Superman it's literally a fashion
accessory he walked by the window at dam
portions of Solitude he's go this looks
like a frog man this is horrible
they took his baby blanket to cuddle up
in yeah if you feeling bad about it says
oh damn look at that and so I did that I
think every day there's a whole bunch of
superheroes in a group it looks like a
costume party yes this the weirdest
spider-man get that fixed like it's
dirty or something is he going a little
dry cleaners somewhere you know listen
somebody had gone hey yeah what do you
do with all these suits what do you wear
does he make them yeah and how do you
fasten this piece to here I think too
much right yeah you're the
I was with you on some of it that one if
you're yelling that out in the theater
they're gonna kill you okay I do is
where's his dry cleaner you remember
we're not gonna go with you on that do
you know what did you remember Batman
Bane remember that guy
yeah Bane couldn't hear a word he said
sure so I yell out of the theater how
does that guy eat anything you add that
whole thing put on in Afghanistan prison
which could have Cedars or something I
never going to a movie with you by the
way I did a movie that was written very
well it didn't come out like we planned
it's called zoom Academy shortened to
zoom and I played a superhero and I was
thinking Deadpool does it he does it a
couple times get into a superhero suit
took four men and a bucket of talcum
powder yes and 40 minutes and be gone
it's squeezed there's no way those
people just do this yeah yeah any girl
that puts pantyhose on do they still
have those am I gonna get no look at
them staring at me like no remember do
you know where you are right this a
Viking or a visitor what is it we don't
even know what happened there
you